yep agenda items one and two apologies
for absence and substitutes we have
received apologies for absence from
councillor phil shaw who will be
substituted by councillor roger
constable and councillor arthur williams
who will be substituted by james gooding
thank you both
if we've got any other
apologies
no
non-members attending councillor joe
mcpherson
minutes of the meeting held on the 22nd
of march 2022
and 31st of march 2022 are these agreed
members
thank you
item five to receive declarations of
interest
is there any members
no members indicated
item six land of north
land north of london road west of aurora
the industrial state
royal lane rally
and katy rogers will present thank you
thank you very much can you hear me okay
chairman this application relates to two
parcels of land at a site known as land
north of london road
the parcels are both west of the spine
road so that's the spine mode running
down there and they're both west of that
and they're both north of the um the
roareth brook
the western boundary of both parcels um
will adjoin strategic open green space
in this area here
and the parcels are part of a wider site
which is subject to outline planning
permission for largely
residential
development
the principle of residential development
on this site is therefore already been
accepted
and this application seeks reserve
matters approval relating to the layout
scale and appearance of the proposed
dwellings and the landscaping and access
arrangements
so in total 76 dwellings are proposed
and the plan on screen shows how the
buildings would be positioned i'll just
zoom into the
northern parcel
is it a bit quiet still i'll move it
over there i think that does that sound
better is that better i think it's a bit
high i don't know
i think we'll try that's better isn't it
very good
okay so
this is the um the northern parcel and
you can see that detached properties are
proposed in the northern
and central parts of this parcel
dwellings will be positioned facing onto
the spine road and positioned facing
onto the open green space to the west
relationship of dwellings to the street
and open space would mimic that of
dwellings approved in other phases of
the site including on the opposite side
of the spine road in this phase here
in terms of the relationship of
dwellings proposed to one another it's
considered that this would be acceptable
a planning condition is however
recommended which would remove permitted
development rights for two-story rear
extensions to some of the dwellings in
this parcel given the separation
distances between them
where dwellings would occupy corner
plots so like here here and then there's
quite a few corners because we've got
the access road coming through there
care has been taken to make sure that
the side elevations of these dwellings
were also fenestrated
to add visual interest in the street
scene
all of the dwellings would benefit from
an enclosed rear garden
and on-site parking provision
there was also a number of
unallocated visitor parking spaces um
but it's there's one there they're
dotted about there's one here
um
and and one here in this parcel
and also one there these are marked with
a v on the plan but obviously it's too
small to see that detail
at the southern end of this parcel
i'll just scroll down
so in this position here
a flatted block is proposed this will be
cited opposite a similar flatted block
um to the northern boundary of the
southern parcel
the two would be separated by an area of
open green space through here with a
link through to the um
open the wider area of open green space
to the west
it is considered that the relationship
between the proposed flooded blocks and
nearby existing dwellings the closest of
which are to the east on the spine road
so over here
would be acceptable
some of the windows in the flooded block
would face east but these would overlook
the public realm of the spine road and
the front elevations of nearby dwellings
rather than the rear windows where a
greater degree of privacy would be
expected
there will be sufficient separation of
the flooded blocks to these nearby
dwellings to guard against the degree of
a degree of overshadowing which would be
unacceptable so you've got the full
width of the spine road which includes
grass verge and a swale to one side as
well
again if i just scroll down so you can
see the layout in the southern parcel
so again dwellings in the southern
parcel would face onto the spine road
or to the open so onto here or to the
open space to the west or onto the
little sort of pocket amenity green
positioned here
the two dwellings to the south
so to the southern boundary here and
would have side elevations onto the
southern boundary but these would be
fenestrated
to allow for passive surveillance of
what
will be an another amenity sort of green
space provided in the parcel that's
adjacent to the south
as well as the pedestrian route through
to the open space to the west between
the two parcels the proposed layout will
provide other opportunities for
pedestrian routes through
so one to the southern boundary here
obviously along this access road and
through here
and there's also
footways footpaths provided through this
amenity green space
if i scroll up
so in addition there'd be an access for
pedestrians to enter the open space to
the west at this point here
um
just zoom out
four vehicular accesses off the spine
mode are proposed to serve the
development parcel so one here one here
one here
and
sorry another one
here
and three of those so this one here so
the main sort of t-junction accesses um
already have reserved matters approval
as part of a reserve matters application
for that included the spine road so this
this one here is the additional
vehicle crossover which would just serve
the handful of dwellings in this
location here
take you to one of the house type plans
so there are
a number of different house types
proposed and this is just one of the
larger detached houses which features
small and dormer windows to the front
roof plane this house type is very
similar to the house types approved in
phase one
or one of the house types approved in
phase one
and this plan shows the dwelling in red
brick but across the site a mix of red
brick buff brick alongside some render
and weather boarding is proposed
so this is one of the flutter block
elevation plans
both of the flatted blocks would be
three-story and in scale form and
appearance the two flattened blocks
would be similar to the flatted blocks
already approved and constructed within
phase one
the flats would feature external
balconies and be finished in a mix of
weatherboarding and brick
so let me take you to some of the street
scenes just to give you a general
impression of the the types of dwellings
that are proposed um these street scenes
show the mix of external facing
materials proposed and some of the
different house types only a few
semi-detached dwellings are proposed
some of which are shown
on the bottom street scene so the pair
here and a pair here
so on the first on the top two street
scenes so this is d d and e e e here
you can see the treatment of side
elevations that would face the public
realm so it's a bit small but these are
all side elevations so they're not the
main frontage but they're all
fenestrated to add interest and this is
the southern boundary of the
southern parcel and this would face onto
some
public open space
this is the point of connectivity
through to that public open space and
for pedestrians on this point of the
southern boundary here
the boundary treatment here along this
southern boundary is a brick wall and
with brick pillars between which would
be some timber boarding
and this is typical or
the main sort of publicly visible
boundaries throughout the site would be
in in a kind of robust brick finish um
it would be the boundaries between the
sort of gardens that aren't publicly
visible that would be formed of clothes
boarded fencing
on the bottom street scene you can see
um
this part of the site is the part that
has the greatest change in land levels
this flatted block here
is the flatted block in the southern
portion of the northern parcel
and it's at a lower point within the
site
so landscaping is also a consideration
for this reserve matters application and
you can see from the plan on screen you
might have to zoom in a little bit
because uh because of the scale but
the
the green
circles
indicate new tree planting within the
red line boundary of this application
site and there are a significant number
of new trees proposed you'll also see
within the open space and within the
sort of spine road landscaping to the
side there are also trees proposed there
they're shown in the circles that
are white
in colour
in addition to new tree planting
there are shrub planting and
hedge planting along the boundaries
and the amenity green space which is
in the southern parcel
here
would feature trees
hedge planting but would be largely
later laid to grasp
officers consider that the 76 dwellings
proposed will be laid out in a way which
responds positively to the spine road
and adjacent residential parcels and
open space
let's go
the scale form and appearance of
buildings would be in keeping with the
context of the site and positive in
terms of the effect on visual amenity
the proposed soft landscaping including
a significant amount of tree planting
would also contribute to the overall
high standard of design that would be
achieved
officers do recommend that condition two
is amended slightly simply to delete the
duplicate plan reference and that
condition five is amended to reference
plan number
p1641 rather than as stated
16241 it's just a typo
in addition condition 13 is to reference
the approved materials schedule and plan
but subject to these changes the
recommendation chairman is one of
approval subject to the recommended
conditions
thank you
thank you katie
we have one public speaker for this item
mr robert hoy who's an objector
would you like to come and sit up here
mr hoyer
and the microphone will be given to you
that you have five minutes to speak
and i'll remind you when you've got one
minute to go no worries thank you very
much
can you hear me okay
good stuff good good
so i think first and foremost um
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to speak this evening um and i guess um
you know
um give you an insight about my
representations and objections to the um
the planned uh proposal now specifically
i don't have an issue with the majority
of this
um i think it's key to
indicate and highlight my main issues
around the flats
of which i i i believe and understand
involves an element or majority of
social housing
and
i think it's important to
go through a few bits around my concerns
of anti-social behaviour and criminality
that i believe will
succumb if if those if those flats are
installed in their current locations and
now i completely accept and i'm
certainly not naive to the fact that
certainly when i bought a property on
the on the estate that there would be
social housing and i certainly have no
objection we need to look after these
people
and we need to to ensure that certain
people that perhaps aren't as privileged
as you and i
um certainly have a roof over their
heads however
where the flats are um where the
proposal is for those two flats which
are located um as i say sort of south
westerly on on the spine road i know
more than around 200 yards or so from a
park and recreational area
now
in a in a former life i was a detective
constable for essex police and i think
probably to
perhaps give you an understanding about
until some context around my concerns
probably perhaps to give you a live sort
of example and bring this to life
and hopefully you'll be able to
understand why i have projections to to
where those flats are located
um first and foremost um
i think
um
as i say the the flats located in
proximity near to a park and
recreational area causes me real concern
especially as i say around criminality
and anti-social behaviour
when i was a detective constable for
essex police um which i predominantly
looked after the baseline district
castle point and rochford rayleigh area
and dealing with serious and high level
crime
um we had a big issue in castle point um
around a place called john burroughs
park and in john burroughs park you have
a block of flats called selby house
and selby house
housed um
people from the local area it was social
housing and unfortunately with social
housing becomes vulnerable people people
that as i said not as privileged as you
and i people that are exposed to perhaps
backgrounds of criminality people that
are exposed to
low income or no income at all um and
unfortunately
that vulnerability can at times lead to
addictions
now not for one moment am i saying that
those flats will be
full of individuals that will
be recreational or drug addicts but it
certainly exposes it to a risk
and it's all about to me it's about risk
mitigation and that i think that's quite
key tonight it's not about it's not
about you know having social housing on
on the build estates it's a risk
acceptance that we have to accept in
this in this day and age but to me it's
about mitigating those risks and i think
you know a study by nottingham and trent
university um which was which was
undertaken in recent years
proved and shown that social housing or
new build estates increased crime levels
in the area you can't get away from that
that's a matter of fact but we have to
accept that
but we have to we have to mitigate that
now what happened with solby solby house
in john barrows park was being only a
stone's throw from a park area
recreational area
it meant that
local drug runners county line drug
runners um prayed and vulnerable
individuals within those flats and used
that though that park
as a hub as a point of contact
see one minute left okay they use that
as a part they use that as an area as a
hub to deal um and supply
drugs from now you may or may not know
but rocha and rayleigh on a good night
with a full capacity of police officers
has between four and six police officers
that's without taking in holiday
absences extension of duties scene
guards hospital guards whatever it might
be so as far as i'm concerned having
a block of flats situated probably no
more than about 200 yards from a park
and a recreational area prevents real
concern for me whether where phase one
currently is where the flats were built
they were built on the main road in a in
a densely populated area near an
industrial state away from recreational
you recreational
areas that will be used by young
children and families and i think as i
say i accept that these that these
areas need to be
provided to social
but we need to ensure that they're
placed in certain areas where we can at
least mitigate those risks to the area
thank you thank you very much thanks
thanks for your time thank you very much
sorry to have to cut you off
there's no visiting members want to
speak on this
no thank you councilman person the wall
councillor is uh councillor stanley um
uh five minutes please cancel slowly
thank you
thank you chairman
um
i asked the question to the
officers
um
why why is it that we we've got policies
of
size of gardens
size of parking bays
and yet we're not adhering to those
policies that we've got
um
i'd like to know the reason why we're
not adhering to that
and the fact that
um
we've got these if you like social
housing all in one place that's opposite
each other
why have we not pepper potted them
around
as we have got a policy of having to do
that why is that not done so
um
the fact that
it has been reported by the police
service
that there is
criminality when we hold them all
together
in one place and this could become
detrimental to
the council itself in controlling
the area
and how we
how the residents
will
succumb to that sort of
if you like difficulty
i also have problems with
parking as there is insufficient parking
in the area
in these areas
um
because
if you i know we're going to say one
bedroom flat is going to have one
parking space but it needs two parking
spaces as it will be controlled by
two people
if it if it is a double if it's a double
bedroom
and not
there are there's going to be two people
there and they'll both have cars so we
haven't got parking space for those for
the extra
so there's there's these questions that
need to be answered and um i feel sure
that you you'll find that
an answer for them thank you thank you
council stanley
should i take those questions now oh
yeah yeah thank you um
so let me just see if i can get
another plan on the screen
zoom out a little bit
okay so the plan on the screen um is is
an
analysis of the garden areas um for the
dwellings and the ones that are
highlighted in the darker blue color so
there's two here
one two nearby each other here and one
here
are the ones that don't quite meet the
hundred square meter
reference in the supplementary planning
document
but the supplementary planning document
goes on to say that um
dwellings will be expected to be
provided with 100 square meters unless
they are positioned um
adjacent to an area of well-maintained
public open space
and so
we've taken these these are not hugely
under provision
so i think um forgive me i haven't got
the precise point at which this is
referred to in the in the report um but
i think it might be
around five square meters um that we're
talking about and some of these got
these these five gardens being short but
because they're positioned
immediately opposite
um
a large substantial area of well which
will be well maintained public open
space we're of the view that
this wouldn't conflict with your
supplementary planning
guidance
in respect of garden areas
in terms of parking bays
um
the parking bays proposed do meet the
preferred base size of 2.9 by 5.5 i
think your reference might be to the
garage
the garages that are provided but
because these garages essentially are
in addition
to the two spaces that are provided
on plot that do meet the 2.9 by 5.5
they don't need to qualify as an actual
parking bay
and they still would be of a size that
are usable as a garage
but they just wouldn't meet the 7x3
meter standard but because they're in
addition we are of the view that the
parking that's proposed would would meet
the council's preferred base size
standard
um in terms of
pepper potting the affordable if i just
go back to the
site
um
i'll go back to this plan first
and just point out to you where the
affordable housing is going to be on or
propose to be so that's in this flatted
block here
in this flooded block here
and then you you might be able to see
that this terrace and these two
semi-detached properties have blue dots
on them and they're also affordable
properties
so
whilst it's true to say that the
affordable housing that's proposed is
not
you know as separated out throughout the
these parcels as it could be in theory
you know
when you look at the site the wider site
as a whole
actually this sort of cluster of
affordable housing here
is is not adjacent to any affordable
housing in this adjacent parcel which um
is under construction
law um the nearest affordable housing i
well there's some if i am what i might
do
is bring up another plan
so this isn't an app this isn't one of
the applicants submitted plans but it
just shows the wider context only a
little bit of the site so
whilst all the layouts not provided what
you've got is a proposal for an
affordable flatted block here one in the
north and part of the southern parcel
here and then some
houses that would be affordable homes
here
but in this adjacent parcel in this bit
you've got no affordable housing the
affordable housing in this parcel is is
over this side and then you've got some
in the phase one which is the flatted
block that some of you might have seen
it's constructed is over here so
actually in terms of the overall site
what what you are getting is
you know some separation of the
affordable homes throughout
it is also the case that
when
particularly flatted schemes you know
they're managed by affordable housing
providers and so you need
usually they want all of the
scheme to be affordable
rather than a mix of market and
affordable within that same block and
for management purposes
so that's possibly one of the reasons
why developers propose flatted blocks
that are either entirely market housing
or either entirely affordable housing
and i said the affordable block we've
accepted in phase one
to the north
in terms of the the parking provision
i think there was reference to the
you know one bed flats maybe requiring
two spaces
um but asked at the standard does
require one space for a one bed flat and
i don't think there would be grounds for
us to insist on on any greater
proportion of parking for those
properties
thank you very much
would you like a supplementary question
yes yes please thank you
i
understand what you're saying um
but i still consider that uh the three
blocks or the three areas that has got
affordable housing could be separated
quite drastically on that plan and i
also would like to see
some provision of parking extra parking
not just adequate parking but extra
parking in the areas where there is
this problem of spaces to park
as that will overload that whole corner
of vehicles and some and somebody may be
parking or will be parking in front of
other properties where they they can't
park in other words you will have quite
a number of pro
extra cars and there isn't any extra
space there to put any extra load of
vehicles
actually just supposing we just actually
don't know that's the what's going to
happen with the parking can i now go on
to councillorse please
thank you chair thank you a few um
issues i think i want to thank mr hoy
first of all for coming and uh giving us
the benefit of his actual experience
um and i think it would be very remiss
of us if we didn't actually take note
of what he has actually brought to the
to the committee
uh the responsibility for anti-social
behaviour is not only
that of the police but also also of the
council and i'm aware
as mr hoyer has already said that
neither of us have the capacity to deal
with the current
issues
my concern is that we have a policy of
pepper potting
of social housing within the state now
we are
if we approve this as it is at the
moment
uh that is
quite an in uh
intensification um within a single area
that i believe
is an issue that we should
take very seriously on the certainly
with the information that mr hoy has
brought to us tonight
um one of the other things just a small
um
thing reading through the report a lot
of trees proposed to be through this
through the site it's well known that
new trees when they're planted within
the first two years are quite vulnerable
i'd like to see a condition put in there
that
there is a treasure surveyed after two
years and any that have died are
replaced
so
i think that uh
for myself i look at where the social
housing is and i think i agree with
councillor stanley that they should be
split up and spread around the uh
this proposed area
to prevent
the kind of criminality that i believe
is is a genuine concern
uh that mr hoya has brought to us
tonight and i think that we should take
that very seriously thank you thank you
katie
could we put a condition on regarding
the trees sorry on that tree condition
the standard landscaping condition that
we have um
already requires that if any of the
planting including
trees um dies or is removed or for any
other reason is not there you know um
within five years after planting it must
be replanted on the same basis so that's
that's covered thank you
and i think
sorry was there another question to come
back to or well i think you've actually
explained why
i just want to clarify you have actually
completely clarified why
it cannot be pepper potted any further
than it already is is that correct
well um sorry obviously the
recommendation is for approval so
officers are content that where the
affordable housing is cited
is acceptable
when you take the site as a whole you
know the affordable housing is not all
clustered in one location i think we
haven't interpreted pepper potting
in my experience
in terms of requiring it to be you know
you know
spread out evenly across any site
and i think what we what we've looked at
in this case is that the access into um
this affordable block here um is is via
this point here um and the the access to
this um affordable block is via this
access point here i think um when you
look at this street scene
you know this will be read kind of as a
whole and it includes a mix of
affordable
market housing um
obviously the flatted blocks are of a
scale and form and appearance of their
own um but the the dwellings um yes
there's a terrace here
and the semi-detached pair that's
affordable are not exactly the same form
and appearance as this semi-detached
pair on the corner here but partly
that's because this property on the
corners got to turn the corner and
respond to this street scene as well
but they don't look vastly dissimilar if
you like so if you were the lay person
walking along you you probably wouldn't
spot that you know that that's
affordable and that's not um and i think
whilst i'm mindful of the kind of social
issues that have been raised
that potentially there's a concern that
that relates to affordable housing i
don't think we
in terms of planning can
attribute you know
social um disturbance you know problems
to just affordable homes
i think there's a there's maybe a danger
that there's some level of um sort of
discrimination against um the the
occupants of of these these these
potential homes
and i should maybe point out as well
that um there is there's
there is a difference so some of the
flats would be um affordable rent yes um
but these this cluster here are shared
ownership homes so
thank you very much councillor fd
have you got a mic yes you have
you've got cancer after you've got five
minutes
hello right thank you chairman um two
things
one
taking into account mr says i looked at
the the essex police
and i find it quite disturbing that the
published documents that have been
studied by essex police they can't come
to
any form
decision to shoot to the national pub
planning policy framework and i'm very
very reluctant to
grant this through on that um very very
reluctant
and i'd actually move for a deferment on
this so it can actually be
discussed properly and actually get some
sort of
commitment from the police
and also about the affordable housing
i'm
i understand what katie says about flats
the management company wanting to
control the flats of the foldable but if
it's a mixture the flats would be better
and i think we should always strive for
better
so that's why i'm putting this on i'm
moving for a deferment on this because
of the essex police
could i
um just
can i just comment on the ethics police
response
um
so i think the essex police resp
or we see we consult the essex police
and they do make reference to not being
able to um
or the published documents don't provide
sufficient detail um i think sometimes
the essex police want um secure by
design accreditation to be achieved
and that relates
to things such as the types of locks
that go on doors and windows
and those aren't things that we can
insist on from a planning perspective so
we wouldn't be appropriate and we
haven't imposed conditions on other
developers to require that to secure by
design accreditation be reached whilst
we would encourage a developer to to to
get that accreditation um i think why
where we can sort as police is about the
layout
okay so the layout of buildings um and
how the buildings relate to open spaces
so that we don't create um
kind of
secluded areas you know where there
might be potential for antisocial
behavior
and so well essex police have been
provided with a full layout
of this site and we have looked at it so
as well as ethics police being consulted
we do take into account and look at
layouts in that
regard and so
that's why i spoke in my presentation
about passive surveillance and making
sure that all kind of open spaces so
this amenity green space here has all
these dwellings
looking onto that space all the windows
in those dwellings are eyes onto that
space and so that encourages hopefully
or deters maybe um anti-social behavior
within that area because there's lots of
eyes on on on you
and the same goes for the western
boundary so what we haven't got in this
layout is kind of lots of closed boarded
fencing rear garden boundaries you know
blocking off if you like or facing onto
the the open spaces within the site so i
think officers have looked at it and
we're
we're quite satisfied that this layout
does achieve um good legibility good
pedestrian routes through and the
orientation of dwellings such that
there'd be lots of you know windows and
eyes on streets and and not designing in
any potential for anti-social behavior
into the layout
thank you very much
council foster did you want to talk on
the defender thank you chairman could
you put that last
picture back up please oh yeah and it's
gone i don't know there we go
just a question assuming there is a need
for that amount of flattened building
uh let's say the one in the middle
section has moved up to the north to the
northern is there any evidence that that
would make any difference to
anticipation
well
all i would comment is that the
i think that there was
i didn't point out to you but this space
here is not within the application site
but this is where the playground is okay
so this is the main playground area the
main well the open space playground that
was referred to i think but there's also
this big area of open space here
and then there's these little pocket as
well at green space if you in you know
hypothetically moved this flatted block
up here that would be closer to the
playground i mean we as officers don't
have any issue in terms of
planning in terms of the location of
these affordable houses and the flatted
blocks in proximity to the play area
actually in some regards you know
you know children you know living in the
flats you know will benefit from being
kind of in close proximity to a
playground
thank you
smith
thank you
i absolutely don't support the
promotion
microphone please sufficient information
in the report to come up with a decision
in terms of the essex police the
comments this evening have been around
layout absolutely there is enough
information presented there to determine
layout there might not as the officers
have
explained to us
be not enough information to do with the
construction of the door locks and uh
and other things like that but in terms
of layout there is absolutely enough
information for the police to have made
a decision and their their decision
would be about the whole site it
wouldn't be stigmatizing as it appears
to be happening this evening the social
housing i don't support the
move for deferral and i'm quite happy
that i have more than sufficient
information to make an informed decision
on planning matters thank you
thank you members we have a motion on
the table and it's been seconded for a
deferment can i have
a show of hands for deferment please in
favor of department
and please keep that as well sign your
counsel and thank you
members of against deferment please have
a show of hands
members
there's
4 45 firmament and eight against
determinants so that is the lost memphis
we'll go back to the original motion
the recommendation is set out on
paragraph 1.1 of the report on pages 6.1
to 6.5 again voting will be done by a
show of hands all in favor
of
oh i haven't i've got a second to please
a counselor smith thank you
members can i have a
show of hands in favor of this
recommendation
thank you members against please
[Music]
and council stanley would like to record
it of course thank you
so that's eight four
four again and councillor stanley's vote
has been recorded thank you members that
motion has been carried
members going on to item seven
this is the seven arterial park chelsea
road rally
uh mr strengths will represent the
officer's report thank you mike thank
you chairman if we just uh
await the first plan there's only two of
the set that i'm going to show you
um thank you
that's great moving up a little bit
chairman we're looking at the middle
unit here of this uh new estate that
some some members might have seen on the
way
yep okay i was trying not to resonate
but um okay um
we're looking at this middle unit here
members remember when we looked at the
outline permission it was a hybrid
giving you details of the first phase
which has been advanced if not finished
stage of construction and occupied
leaving the balance of the remainder of
the site to be developed
we've got a simple small application
really for some extract flues the the
middle unit is occupied by a company i
think they're a national chain who uh do
accident repairs and if we could jump to
the elevations please
um we'll see they've got three flues on
the back of the building that the
elevation is split there that's the
front it was a combined application with
some signage which has been dealt with
separately but we've got the application
for these three flues these serve uh a
spray booth that's inside the the
building
and you'll see that there's three
different sizes there's this larger one
which is 900 mil
in diameter it extends um about 1.5
meters above the roof line they're
saying in the particulars it won't be
visible above the shape but they've
given us the nearest sections of the
roof because obviously to create draft
on this one you need it to be a certain
height above then there's a smaller
diameter one
that just appears marginally above the
uh
above the edge of the roof it's nearest
to by 0.26 less than one foot um above
there and then the last one is a round
grill like we have we often see on
housing there's just a vent in the in
the wall
and that again is about 900 mil in
diameter so those three different
extract flues they contain
the filters and things that are used um
in the process
they are quite typical in design they're
made of a uh anodized um steel
uh they're typical to industrial areas
um there's no real harm to the
architecture of the group of buildings
and given that chairman the
recommendation to you is to approve
subject to the conditions set out in the
report
thank you we've got no public speakers
um councilman furson do you would you
like to speak on this she's gone
obviously not
that's a no then
uh we haven't got um the world member
any world member here to speak on it
have we anyone wishing to speak on it oh
we've got quite a few
councillor fd
thank you chairman
thank you chairman i'm in support of
this i just got a question
this is the site with the proposed
traveler site on it would there be
any problems with the flues with the
distance
would that have any effect i know it
says neighbors and stuff but they're not
there yet and they'd be in the open
and that's quite a distance but just to
have interest right
thank you jim the
traveler's site as you'd say is
allocated here the unit itself is over
here and there'll be other development
in this intervening part but our
colleagues in environmental health um we
was able to get a reply from them today
and they're very happy with the
apparatus used um i think there's a
figure here that they've said
it'll catch 99
of the discharge there's three filters
which is possibly why we've got three
different techniques of exhaust one that
takes out paint particles one that takes
out certain solvents one that takes out
other
substances and the paints i think are
water-based which they say are better
for the environment as well one other
thing the eho examined in the particular
submitted was that normally i think
under law they have to be replaced
everything 14 months these guys want to
they say they want to do it every six
months so their
to the management of the discharge
seems to be a lot more positive
than they need to be so our
environmental health officer has no
problem in advising that from what he
can see from the application submitted
and what they've said
that this should be the minimal of of uh
impact um if members are concerned about
that thank you thank you cancer foster
my question thank you council stanley
yes thank you chairman just just one
point um
when you turn around and say 99 of it
will be collated or collected in the
uh fine
uh
detail of how it works
do we know what that one percent
is that's going to be extracted into the
air
and and is it in as it is in
if it's in the right wind change to to
where
people are
do we know what effect that might have
on those people
chairman the um reading from what he
said this setup is rated to remove 99 of
paint particles
so i think
his message in simple terms is that this
is
good kit as it were
to do the job i can't help you with
the science the actual concentrations
etc but if something is 99 good uh doing
the job i think he would have expected
in his experience that as an authority
we often perhaps see less and less is
acceptable this is why above what we
normally find so he was quite confident
there are so excited about the fact that
these people seem to be putting in good
kit to do the job he had no qualms with
recommending to me to recommend to you
that this is this is okay but i can't
help you with the
sort of sample sciences of
you know the particles so we don't so we
don't actually know what that one
percent is over a long term he's that's
what we're saying is it his says he is
it's rated to remove 99 of paint
[Music]
we're never going to get 100
i'd just like to say that that um
it was considered um okay for children
coming out of school now we're not
talking for those people
one percent
uh coming out of school we're coming out
of an industrial state yes that's just
the point he's coming out of an
industrial site not out of cars with
children walking past school we've had a
report to say that's the top rate we can
get
i don't think we can get any further on
this i really don't unless someone can
actually say that i'm wrong well i think
we can because filters are made
can you then please provide evidence
where you can get something a hundred
percent
yes
where is it
in
in poland i can't bring it to you at
this moment in time but i can give you i
can give you
absolutely counselor stanley if you come
to a committee meeting with
um facts we need them in writing so we
can everyone can have evidence of them
if you can't evidence them tonight we
cannot consider them i'm afraid
if you'd have read the report you'd seen
that you had an issue um our officers
would have answered these and come back
to you which you clearly didn't go back
so i'm going to move on is anyone else
want to speak i'm going to go through to
the recommendation
oh sorry roger i didn't see you sorry
councillor i didn't see you
you uh talk about
their flues coming out my
understanding of the flu would be from
gases and stuff like that so are they
flues or are they extract ducks
just
clarify the terminology chairman i think
the terminology they've used in the
application is a flu but i think i used
in my reply they're exhausted my
understanding is that the spray booth
that would be inside the building
whether because of pressure and you know
if you're spraying you get all the paint
in the air and everything else it needs
to be extracted but on the way to being
extracted and sucked out they have all
these filters in the different systems
i've in my experience i've never seen a
system with three before but then i'm
not always looking for it so
and just deal with the application that
we're given
but we've consulted as part of our work
the council's environmental health
offices and they from time to time do a
lot of this i mean with things like
takeaways they often say that there's
nothing wrong with the kit it's the
maintenance regime they don't change the
filters enough and that's why you get
the smells from cooking and things like
this but when the guys we asked for a
view for you tonight on this when he see
that their attitude is to recharge the
filters more quickly than is required by
environmental health law yeah that
wasn't the the question i was asking you
it was just on the terminology of
the extract that whether it's the duct
or whether it's the flu because my
understanding of a flu would be from say
a gas appliance or
um yeah this is this is for paint
spraying where they use pressurized air
now they've used the term flu
whether that's the correct term i
couldn't
answer you but what they contain is they
suck out
the particulars
they contain filters that clean up if
you like to discharge
and
our own
officers who specialise in this
they say they're approached by the
applicants and the kit that they are
using is very good
thank you
any other member no oh sorry councillor
smith
chairman i'm quite happy to take the
expert professional and experienced
thank you
the recommendation is set out at
paragraph 1.1 on the report 7.1 to 7.2
members can i have a show of hands in
favor of this application please
against abstain
so that's seven four
now eleven four and one abstention
thank you members that's carried
members we're now on to 8.1 which have
you all got
yup
just make sure you've all got the coffee
here
and this is landfronting29 the chase
fell ness island and again it will be um
my strength to do the report please
thank you chairman um this application
is to a site to the north east of
falness island
um
it's one of a small grouping of
dwellings that you see
scattered about in these areas we're
looking at this area here
the
chase forms you'll see
three
terraces of three dwellings which front
onto this part there's the chase running
through
the
sort of broadly east west direction but
you'll see that there's a crescent
with access both ends that serves this
small
group of dwellings
if we could look there's a verge there
if we can jump to the photographs please
two planned photographs here we see the
uh western end there's the chase there's
a ditch here which we'll talk about in a
moment
and there's an access point at the
beginning of the terrace if we scroll
down on this set
we then look in the opposite direction
and that's the western end where the
crescent exits or enters depending which
direction you're coming from and while
we're here i'd like you to just ponder
on the condition of the ditch but also
this verge area here that you see is
rutted where perhaps in wet weather
vehicles have had to overtake or park i
think the first photograph we saw we
actually saw some vehicles parked there
if we can
jump to the next one please just go
through these photos of how it is here
we see a little bit of parking that's
provided for residents on just sort of
time act area but as you go through
these if members can note that all these
front cartilages just got pedestrian
gates there doesn't seem to be any uh
garaging or drivings to the side of
these properties if we could continue
please katie
it's more of the same just inching along
if we keep going
and we get to the end this is towards
the end of the present i think is there
one more of the end shot no that's all
right that's fine obviously we have
there so we've gone back to where we
started and you'll see there's front
boundary fences the parking that's
available is in where you can just see
the the car in the corner of the picture
there
if we could go to the site layout plan
three please
what's before you tonight chairman is a
proposal to construct 19 car parking
spaces we've just looked at this verge
area here
and you'll see that some are in like a
herringbone pattern
in front of the dwellings and you'll see
a larger group directly accessing off
the chase itself the blue the four blue
ones are
the electric vehicle charging
and you'll see there's two disabled
spaces marked in in yellow as well
they're laid out to your preferred
standard
and what the applicants say
is that there's a need we we saw the
evidence of the vehicle rutting on the
verge
but there's a need to make provision for
car parking there's operational issues
from time to time where
vehicles or agricultural vehicles need
to pass up and down the road
and they may be obstructed by parking
but there's also the applicants say
people living in the houses and on the
island as they get older
it's not that they necessarily need
parking for themselves but they get
carers visitors delivery drivers things
like this there's a need to accommodate
that without causing congestion so
there's operational reasons
and there's the other reason just to
make the provision clear of the street
so they don't get damaged to the verges
and the landscaped areas that we have
this application
came in initially in 2021
and the case offer was able to
negotiate it down if you call it that
way it was 25 spaces and because there's
nine dwellings the two car parking
spaces
for each dwelling that would be required
would require 18 spaces and to have
perfect compliance given the remoteness
of this site you would want 21 spaces
but they're they're settling on 19 so
they're actually if you like two visitor
spaces short now because access to this
site is controlled i myself was denied
access this morning to go and check one
or two things out
officers feel we can live with the
[Music]
shortfall in visitor parking spaces
because it's managed very much managed
so
visiting is planned and booked by
appointment
and
in that circumstance the improvement to
car parking here
officers feel
could be accepted
there is um a concern about flood risk
that's been cropped up here the
applicants are saying this there's no
outfall to this ditch area
and the environment agency you'll see in
the history of the report have been
consulted backwards and forwards and now
raised no objection agreeing the
applicant's findings
one of the reasons i wanted to get on
there this morning was because to dig
around or double check down here if
there's a buried pipe which i suspect is
the concerns the locals
um probably know when these roads were
put in and know if there was a pipe put
in
if we can look at the next set of uh
flat photographs please
katie um there's a photograph on you see
those one two three fours there's four
photographs here if we can scroll down i
think it's a scroll
there we go
um
this area here is one of the culverts
now i can't make out if that's a
concrete lip to a pipe which it may be
i could only have a better look if i was
there or whether that's actually grass
mowings from the work that's been done
that have just fell down and
rested on some kind of large leaf or
grass
but the applicants who i've spoke to
today
say
known the site for nine years they don't
recall there being any pipe there they
haven't seen any and if there is a pipe
they say that it's well buried it
wouldn't be that feature that i'm
pointing out to you now
so
um in the dialogue that i've had today
and the emails with the applicants
whilst they're comfortable with the
submission they've put before you
if members were still concerned that
this ditch would have a
flooding function in event a breach of
sea wall and dispersal of water
or they're not prepared to accept the
natural drainage as water rain waters
seeping away
the applicants would accept a condition
that we could explore
this we could have a survey to explore
whether a pipe exists and then if a pipe
does exist
a step then that they would have to pipe
this run
before filling it over and installing
the car park
as it stands officers are recommending
to you as per the recommendation but
given the concerns raised by local
people and i think members may be
concerned about as well
i think the applicants are meeting us
halfway to say look we can have a better
look
and if we find that there's a pipe there
then they would be agreeable to piping
it
so the recommendation at the moment
chairman is just as set out in the
report
thank you very much
we have obviously member
um
uh you'll have five minutes
and we'll give you a nod when it's a
minute
thank you chairman um can everybody hear
me okay we can wonderful thank you
um
first of all as the officer mentioned
the original application um
as per the document dated on our rdc
website document date fourth of march 21
was for 26 parking spaces
yet this is not mentioned under relevant
planning history
is that relevant to members in making a
decision tonight i don't know
i asked
members if they have taken time to read
the consultation responses
every single house that's every single
house so not one or two perhaps seen as
nimbys but every single house that is
affected by this application
have expressed that they do not wish for
the number of parking spaces
there has never been an issue with
parking
and as the photos show
it will remove a community amenity and
an open space which includes a mature
ash tree
one wonders why we consult when the
residence views are not even considered
would you like a green open space
that you have enjoyed for many years as
you walk out of your house turned into
concrete
so loss of immunity space
open space their view and impact on the
environment offer consideration
now consider the tragedy of the floods
of 1953
and our responsibility to protect our
residents
the officers already mentioned that
there could be a concrete lip
and that the
applicant has only known that area for
around nine years
now the national planning framework
clearly
steers against any development in flood
zone areas
our own core strategy policy env3
supports against development in flood
zones too
foulness island
is in flood zone three
the highest level
falness may be a small community
i suspect many members may never have
visited the island
but
this small community's concerns are as
important as any other part of our
district
a reduction in the number of parking
spaces
with retaining more of their open space
would be a more reasonable option for
consideration
thank you chairman thank you
love
uh councillor fd is uh the wall
councillor as well as the council in
person so he's open to you uh councillor
do you have five minutes
thank you chair
um i've called this in for a couple of
reasons
one is the the flooding
i was there in
2013 i think it was it was within two
centimeters of the whole island being
over
so flooding is a very real issue on that
island really is
um i'm a little bit concerned about
where it says they can take it to hard
standing there's a there's a ditch
there's a ditch there for a reason even
if it's just water coming off the road
which i probably think it is because
i've been on there it's so flat the
roads do flood quite a lot and you get
overshooting of the water so it's
probably built there for one time to
stop the water going into the houses or
the front gardens
so where it says hard stand i'd like to
see and a permeable
um
belonging for the car park
not an impermeable one so it does have a
chance to actually drain away
um
[Music]
again this street scene
you ever been on founders island is
green spaces there's not car parks
everywhere there just isn't
this would be so out of character for
foulness
um reduction
i can't believe i'm saying this because
i'm always fighting for more car parking
spaces
but a reduction
on
spaces in this area i think would be
well
for the street scene
and that's that's about it right thank
you council
[Music]
thank you chairman um it just seemed to
me from the description there are a
number of open questions about potential
pipe connections and stuff like that and
i would propose would defer it till
we've got some more definitive
information actually
thank you have your second time
council reeves
anyone else
yes
um i would
suggest
to members if we are
going to
consider development
then clearly the status of the park is
the principal reason before but you
might as well well may ensure that we
are in a position to determine
the uh the application when it does come
back to us
and ask for
the applicant to comment or give
consideration to the point that
anthropology has made about permeability
of the surface as well
thank you council smith you've just said
what i was going to say um that perhaps
the applicant could look at vulnerable
surface instead of concrete
because then that will let the water go
and maybe reducing the number of parking
spaces counselors
thank you chair i'd also like you
to
be part of the defendant the reasoning
behind why the mod have actually
proposed this when the people who are
actually going to benefit i don't want
it
thank you councillors
darnley
you're talking on the development
council
thank you chairman um as we all know
that ditches are better at
holding water than pipes pipes get
blocked up
so
with this in mind and
of all the ditches that we have and that
we put water into and that's the
environment agency put the water into it
from the roads the the wider the ditch
or the deeper the ditch the better the
holding of water rather than a pipe as
we already know they are they can fail
um
and i can't support this application
oh we're not supporting you're not
talking about um you must have might
miss that council stanley we're actually
talking about deferment
not approval so i will oh right
uh cancer fd
which way you go with your mics
thank you chairman uh is in a way we can
put on the deferment revisiting the
street scene because it's just so
incongruous to the rest of the island
i'll let um the officers come back to
you on that council actually because i
can't obviously can't answer that
sorry chairman i didn't get that that
point there's so much vibration on the
sound could i have it restated
the street scene because it's so
incongruous to the rest of the island
so
if i may come in what would you be
looking for officers to achieve i've got
it that you've said reduction in car
parking spaces gives you back more green
more greenery there so if the surface is
going to be impermeable maybe the uh
color
grass creek
grass greens or the concrete so it'd be
yeah
yeah
so it looked more green
right members um
oh sorry yeah
commitment
council
yeah could we also um include in a
deferment a consultation official
consultation with the residents rather
than hearsay
we've done it twice
and the the this is why the application
has taken so long there's been some uh
issue about it being a second
application i was actually talking with
councillor fd and councillor mcpherson
on the way in
our records don't show an earlier
application there was a batch of these
that came in
last year some of which have been
determined
and this one
started i think the member said earlier
26
spaces i thought i say in the report i
think 25
what the case officer did in response to
the objections we had then was see if
she could like members are saying
tonight get it down so that there was
more
room to landscape yeah
so we consulted on the first application
got those in as a result of those
she got the revisions in
reconsulted residents again on the
revised application so your report sets
out two sets of consultations
a lot of which has come back with the
same issues because although taking the
point that the more green you can get
the better for the residents residents
have got issues with the scheme as a
whole which don't change whether it's 19
15 or 25 spaces yeah
so we have consulted twice
as a matter of planning practice if
the applicants
substantially change the scheme let's
just pretend they came back with 10
then we'd probably take a view that
because that's such a difference from 19
we would again have to reconsult the
neighbors but if they take
just one or two spaces then we'd
probably say well is that serious enough
to warrant a re-consultation with with
the public we know what they say
so it depends what the applicant's
answer is to your questions
but if there's significant enough we
will reconsult anyway as a matter of
course
can i come in there
mike we've got the um
on these pages where um
they've said residents have said well
they don't like them or why are we
having them if they um the applicant
come back and said this is hypothetical
figures i appreciate this and they say
right we will reduce them to ten why do
we need to go out again for consultation
when we've got it uh representation from
the residents
making the decision and following the
process you have to be very careful that
you you don't end up determining
something that the public haven't had
input
so some changes are minor
you get developers come along and they
want to reduce the window by 900 mil or
something and you say well it's not
worth reconsulting on but if they want
to deepen the extension then clearly if
it's significant enough block out light
that sort of thing you should reconsult
same as if
there's an issue around numbers and
greenery it just might be that if they
did really beat the numbers down that
some residents might say
okay
i removed my director i no longer hold
an objection and then
for the purposes of decision you make on
the night you've got a better feel for
how
um people think about it
so some people will hold an objection in
principle all the way through that's
fine
others might share your view that if it
was a smaller scheme they'd find it
acceptable you won't know until you you
asked them but if they if they just took
one space off i'm not sure
it's worth consulting over a small
change like that
we have to wait and see i think what the
what the applicant does but as officers
we tend to be cautious
um with bureaucrats so you know if
there's a change that could possibly
lead to judicial reviews and all sorts
of
like that is far better to tread
cautiously and re-consult so if we don't
end up re-consulting it's probably
pretty clear that it's such a minor
change just bring it back to you as the
applicant says well that's my best shot
uh what they're going to do thank you
for the clarification our members we
have a motion uh put forward
to us and seconded for department can i
have a show of hands for members in
favour of deferment please
members that's unanimous thank you very
much
uh officers
officers you are clear of what the
deferments are thank you people sorry i
should have asked before
thank you members i'd like to say this
is councillor
merrick's last meeting with us and thank
you very much for all the time for what
you've done with us so i wish you uh
good luck in the future with whatever
you do and hope to see you at any thing
we do so thank you very much